hey everyone this is Steve montrove with
collider and I am thrilled to be with
everyone involved in the blackening I
have to ask you guys uh how much are you
the film is premiering I want to start
with congratulations on the movie I know
it's gonna it's gonna play so well
tonight what are you got what is it like
for you guys because it's premiering
tonight World premiere
um what is it like leading up to a world
premiere like this where really no one
has seen it or very few people have seen
it but you know you have something it's
exhilarating it feels like it felt like
magic when we made the movie and we know
that tonight everyone's gonna feel that
magic for sure
oh I'm looking for more answers
from like I think
second they started shooting just
because Cass is magical
So Much Chemistry and I was laughing
just my ass off watching them shoot it I
knew it was like gonna be an incredible
experience so I'm just ready for it I'm
ready I've seen the cut they haven't
actually seen it
so I know something that they don't know
it's it's a crowd pleaser it's amazing I
can't wait wait so I've seen it and you
guys have nothing and we've been doing
presses popped and puffed in ADR they
were like extra running so I'm like
so I saw when I ran and I thought that
was good I think I ran well we have no
idea what but I don't I don't know any
idea what didn't
and I've seen a cut but not this one so
it's real good
no but I mean like uh uh listen I can
also say that uh Tiff knows what they're
doing when they schedule and the fact
that you're the Saturday night I believe
midnight movie they this is they put it
in the you know they know when they play
something on a Saturday night at that
time they have something
um listen most people watching this will
have not seen the movie yet so how have
you been describing the film to friends
and family
um I've been describing it as like um
you know black friends go to a cabin and
they
getting murdered and whatnot so uh and
then they gotta try not to and the fun
that comes with you know trying not to
die one of them
one of the things that I thought was so
well done about the film is I felt like
each character had their own
individuality and like everyone had like
that dimensional like I just felt like
these are real people who've known each
other a long time I believe it's 10
years since you saw each other at
College yeah you know
I may have seen the movie yeah you know
like um uh and so but that's something I
really bought into and can you sort of
talk about making each character feel
like they're an individual when you only
have so much run you know run time if
you will that's a testament to how
wonderfully written it was written by
Tracy and and Dwayne because these
characters were fully fleshed out they
jumped off of the page and then Tim just
gave us the freedom to be exactly who we
were exactly how we saw these characters
and just go for it and it was so nice
that he fostered that that beautiful
environment for us to just kind of
collaborate and and do what we do best
and and have a really great time and it
was just so much fun I can't wait to see
it like yeah I I can't wait yeah I think
that uh it was easy to play these
characters as Antoinette said because I
knew who they were I knew it so clearly
and then I'm an improviser and I come
from sketch comedy and a late night
writing background so I had jokes not
just for myself but for everybody else
and everybody was like welcome to that
like we were always encouraged to pitch
which doesn't happen with every director
or collaborator and I love that there
were moments where like we needed more
nuance and having a writer who's
starring in the film and he could add
like oh that really doesn't subvert
expectations maybe we should do this
maybe we should do that so I think that
was really like our lucky charm that we
had having Dwayne in it who also wrote
it and I do think writing it from jump
the intent was to take tropes and then
expand them to force the audience to
realize that that tropes are also human
beings uh so like my character is a gay
best friend which is a Trope that are in
movies they're the gay best friend and
usually they're regulate it to the side
to be like a person that gives humor or
they're like part of the joke so being
able to like take these tropes and then
find exactly what makes them complex
what gives them depth and then forcing
that into the movie so that when you
start watching it you see what has been
in horror movies before and then the
goal of the movie is to constantly break
down your assumptions of these
characters by constantly forcing depth
so that that is the examination of
Blackness is the characters so that we
don't have to talk about it we can just
be it
oh I'm not sure yeah I'll add I mean I
think what was so brilliant about
Dwayne's original Short was that you
just had this very diverse group of
black people within one friend Circle
and I think what happens at least
because we grew up like loving horror
movies and the joke was like the black
people always diverse and there's always
like one or two and so it was kind of
like well we get to do a horror movie
where everybody's black like all of the
leads are and so when you get an
opportunity to do that you're like wow
we can actually do a really diverse
group of people and kind of dissect it
while also using comedy and humor and
just a lot of like scares so I mean I
thought it was just a really cool
opportunity to do it and I've never seen
a horror movie done like this and we
I'll say this for me and Dwayne we love
scream
um that I found out that Kevin Williams
is like doing something at Tiff right
now thank you I've seen it it's called
sick sick yeah and then and that's just
like of I don't know it feels like
fateful for us because that was
something we talked about a lot and like
to me that was like the movie that did
such a great job of being like meta and
also having like horror and comedy and
stuff and so now we get to do it in our
own way and I just thought it was like
just really cool uh he's coming in
studio I think tomorrow so I'll pass on
that he should see you're moving
yeah I I can make that happen um I have
to know for you guys what was it like
seeing the board game for the first time
um in that room uh because and the
design of in of that board game uh I
remember we were all right
like oh like this is really an imagery
that evokes a certain kind of feeling
and I feel like because of the movie to
take that and then kind of place so much
humor around it kind of like takes the
air out of it while still
giving the space to be like we didn't
make this like this is not an image that
was created by black people
but this is an image that we can take
and repurpose for what we want it to be
so that was kind of like a a powerful
symbolism to me it's kind of taking
uh what was used as like bad and then
repurposing it to make a beautiful
Perfect movie
yeah yeah we were triggered and I was
like oh I'm those reactions were 100
real real like will you purposely not
show it to YouTube we never saw it we
didn't see it until it was time those
were real reactions yeah like real time
when you take the box off the top it
really was like
it was and I think there's nothing
scarier than than for black people like
there's nothing scary than that like I
could see Candyman it but you put that
that face in front of me baby I'm
running you just put it I'm running a
little bit of racism terrifying
terrifying
I obviously we're not going to go
specific at all with this but talk a
little bit about
um figuring out who the villain
ultimately is gonna be in a film like
this and how much like debate went on
deciding ultimately where is the third
act gonna go
I remember we talked a lot about we were
like what are we like what do we
ultimately want to say with what we're
doing yep
um and I'm I'm happy to where we landed
but there was some very deep extensive
conversations that's like
our purpose because we are very
intentional with uh with all the things
that we've done
um and I think
what it turned out to be is a statement
that I think speaks to the conversation
that we were trying to say with the
whole movie is just speaking to
Blackness and how it is specific to each
person and like what that means to a
person on their journey of existence
and on some level that it's a social
construct and that like we always force
people to Define what it is and and
we're kind of like challenging people's
Blackness like left and right and the
movie does that but then ends in a
different way and I will say the thing
that joy and I debated it's hard to kind
of say without revealing the end but we
didn't want to do the obvious thing
and I think that might be clear when
people see it but there's there's an
obvious like villain and we were like
let's subvert that and do something
unexpected and that's something that we
deliberately wanted to do I'm always
curious
um when when you're filming anything
there's always going to be a maybe a day
or two that you circle on the calendar
like you know there's going to be a
tough shooting day or this is going to
be a whatever it may be like a challenge
so for each of you what was the day of
the shoot that like the night before you
were really in your head oh you know
you've seen the movie so I'm sure you
know exactly what day it was for me I
had I had a lot of words to say I had a
lot of feelings about something and so I
was kind of terrified that I wouldn't be
able to go where I needed to go to
harness the kind of feeling that I
needed to harness but it was it was
pretty great because Tim was just like
you know what we're just gonna turn on
the camera and when you're ready let's
just go and it just it wasn't it was
just take your like take your beat we're
already rolling it's not like I just
want you once you feel it go for it and
I went for it but I was I was terrified
because it's a little it's yeah it's a
lot I don't ever express myself in that
way that's how I can say that but yeah
um for me uh definitely the lake
and I think I can say the lake that's
not really a a spoiler
um but Shanika is in the lake and it was
4 30 a.m and um we have been there since
4 P.M and like the first week of
shooting
um we were all three the three light
skins actually were in the that was the
purpose
Dwayne put the three light skins uh
first week of shooting uh nice shoes 4
P.M cute 6 a.m every day
um and it was cold it was coke
um so yeah I would say that that day was
really hard but what uh what I'm so
grateful for is for Melvin and uh Grace
who I was uh accompanied with during
that section of shooting
um because they were so sweet they
constantly checked on me it was like my
first night shoot and this is like my
biggest role to date which I'm very
grateful for Dwayne and Tracy and Tim
for that
um so I was just so happy just to be on
set and although it was difficult having
people that you really [ __ ] like I
mean you really gotta have that because
like this is a com a horror comedy so
it's like we're running and then we're
laughing we run tell a joke it's night
time where do you go oh my God what are
you doing you gotta kill a screen
it was someone screaming like oh my God
we keep screaming
yeah so you really need people that you
really [ __ ] with like we were having
noodle time there's a time we kept
eating a couple noodles and it was like
late at night and we kept doing that we
kept calling out HR just randomly
um and it was it was good about that
running we kept doing a running bit
doing like X oh my God I'm so tired I'm
like I'm calling HR
and but yeah I think you really need
that love of chemistry and I think it
showed on screen I think everybody's
gonna see that for sure yeah yeah I
would say my hardest day was the first
day because I just didn't know what to
expect and because of my position as
like writer and actor I was very
conscious of like oh my emotions like
kind of have to be a certain way in this
dynamic because like I'm thinking about
like the greater picture and I was like
What if I go on set the first day and
all these actors have trash ass energy
like what if it's just like not like a
good vibe like what if like that's
something I'm very conscious just like
as a human just like what is the vibe is
wrong and on day one the vibe was so
right I had my first thing with
Antoinette and Grace and they were both
like why don't you seem happy and I was
like I'm just like regulating my
feelings and then they were like be
happy take pictures and then they just
really like forced me to like come out
of myself and just like love the
experience for what it was and it really
shifted everything to be like oh like
this is not something I like this is
something that I have to like live in in
this moment and really take it for what
it is I've never written and starred in
a movie like this is a literal dream of
mine like oh like live in this and they
really pushed me into that and then made
it worth it like they just really made
this like a core memory in my mind
forever
um our first moment together I was like
hey
that's Tim's story right there this is
your [ __ ]
I'm like come on
and I'm really sitting there like
they're they're like come on do
something I'm like I don't know it's so
cute yeah it really started the film and
the best way there was just so much love
that I really shows through the Ensemble
and that's what I really hope people see
is that like oh this group of people
enjoyed making this movie together yeah
well I think it shows on screen were you
on set it all did you get I was yeah and
I I
it's magical watching
it cracking up
no yeah we don't know either
it was just so much silliness and when
you put like so many comedic people in
one room and then the script is already
insane so it it just I just saw the love
I saw the chemistry and you see it on
screen like you're saying and that's
part of why I think it works is because
I buy that you guys are friends Yes
except with Melvin I hate him yeah we
don't like Melvin let me close the
camera we don't like you know very much
everybody no one was left out but that's
one of the things that when I was
watching is that I really did think you
guys were really friends and it's like a
very funny movie that's also a horror
movie you know what I mean so talk a
little bit about that aspect of knowing
when when do you do you know when you've
gotten it in terms of like as an actor
when you're delivering a line like oh I
got it like this works or are you always
relying on like if you could talk a
little bit about that or is Tim always
saying to you like well you know what
you got it because you're moving on you
you want to know what I noticed on set
the more freedom that we all felt the
more everyone just kind of let go and
once we all let go we started bouncing
off of each other in a way that you
couldn't even anticipate so like you can
think of the ways that a line might
sound like it oh wow this would kind of
be funny when I read it out loud but
when we're in a room together and then
Shanika says one thing and I'm like but
and then we kind of like play with each
other in a way that was just kind of
really beautiful and it's like it was
kind of cohesive for people who didn't
know each other too it was kind of wild
like we just met and just vibed
instantly so shout out Leah Daniels and
and Tim story for for casting yeah I
think the first day that we got together
immediately Grace So competitive but we
love she was like let's play spades and
we were like we were like supposed to do
blocking and then when Tim was like okay
guys we have to do black and we were
like what we like immediately sat down
and we're just like
and like just like the best of friends
and then forgot like oh yeah we're here
to do it yeah this is not just play time
like yeah they're paying us to do
something so it happens like quite quick
and quite immediately but for me I know
I felt comfortable and I knew I had it
once Tim said yes it's time to move on
that's when I knew that it was good and
there was a very important scene with
all of us that was very emotional and
Jermaine Fowler so sweet he saw me
walking away with my head down after we
wrapped because I really felt like I
didn't have it and he texted me and we
like voice noted all night and he like
reassured me about my performance
because it was on my coverage and I
learned so much that day but I'm just so
grateful that I was affirmed to
constantly buy the cast and the director
yeah I would say Tim was really my
Guiding Light because I think because of
the positions that I've had I really
tried to be intentional with like being
an actor I'm gonna like do my job like
act trying to make this as real and
organic as possible and then Tim gonna
let me know if that's good or not
because I know that there's aspects to
this that are not in my control like
Focus sound I'm like oh this is like a
job and so I'm just gonna do what I do
and then trust him that like he's
leading me in the direction that we
should go in and so when Tim said you
got it I said okay I got it let's move
on looks like everyone knew that it was
so special that we all wanted to give
our best and so when you have people who
are constantly hard on themselves trying
to put forth their best at work you kind
of at least I don't I can't speak for
everyone else but like when we're in a
moment together and we're all like just
we've relaxed into the moment and we're
all just like feeding off of each other
moment to moment it feels so right and
it feels like magic so when he says
moving on you're like yeah I felt that I
did feel like yeah
uh this is a little bit more of a real
question
um I'm curious I feel like uh that
Hollywood over the last few years last
five years there's been better rep
examples of representation and more
voices have been being able to tell
their story for you guys do you feel
that way or I mean how do you how do you
see the industry and how things have
gone the last few years
why
I can speak to a lot of that
um I would say from my life there was a
clear difference between pre-girls trip
and post-girls trip for me and the
pre-girls trip life was we've never seen
this work before black women are Niche
we've never like seen them actually have
mainstream success and when I would
reference like The Hangover it would be
like okay but those are men and then if
you say bridesmaids okay but those are
white women and so everyone's telling me
this can't work this can't be mainstream
it can't make money and so when girls
trip like with four black women made 150
million dollars everyone was like oh my
God it can work so then all of a sudden
I could go pitch things like the
blackening or go and and honestly when I
called Dwayne about doing the blackening
it was the same year girl trip came out
and I don't think I would have been able
to like help him sell this movie prior
the year prior I just knew I had to win
dough and so I literally took it out
with Dwayne and we sold it like within
months of girls trip coming out because
I knew I have like momentum and I have a
Halo in this moment and honestly that's
how Blackness Works in this business is
that you're only as good as your last
hit and that hit has to be like within
with a year and so at that point I was
like okay we gotta move we gotta move
and that's just how it's been so I've
seen
I would say like a lot of changes in the
last few years but it's it's all
dependent on like Jordan pill breaking
out with get out you just have to have
different people breaking out and
proving that these things are marketable
and and that there's a place for it
without that you're fighting an uphill
battle so I would say girl strip and
like get out contributed to the black
thing even getting made
what I will say is that my frustration
comes within the industry of giving us
positions and not power so for things
like girls trip and forget out to come
out like it takes uh a non-black to say
like yes this is good this is great this
will do well but if you have us in power
and not in just positions as Studio
execs ask people that are making these
choices for marketing because it's not
just girls trip coming out right it's
not just Harlem coming out it's that
[ __ ] marketing rollout right it's
those pop-up installations it's that for
your consideration panel like we need
support from production to fruition to
marketing so I do not see that enough
for black creatives I feel like they
pick their five you know at one time and
I feel like we don't get enough
um equity and access to take risks to
create at such a high scale of a level
like a girl strip like the blackening
and I feel like somebody like Tim story
I just feel like he is like one of the
few and he is top tier and we were so
blessed to have him be a part of that
but he's just one right like we need
more programs we need more directors we
need more Tracy Olivers and I feel like
we're out there and we have those
stories we're not given the opportunity
I definitely feel the difference
um I feel like a lot of creatives
um people of color black people
specifically have decided to stay true
to their vision of representation of the
characters that they're creating like
well listen this is a black girl she
wears a bonnet when she goes to sleep
like we're going to depict this in
mainstream media because for a very long
time we've all kind of watched the one
tree Hills and stuff like that and I
don't know what it's like to live in
Minnesota
um and and have these experiences but I
identified with the experience because
it was a human experience and so this is
this generation we're feeling a lot of
people not be president like
presentationally black but show us in
our full Essence multi like all these
characters are fully fleshed out
multi-dimensional and you're seeing
different Hues of Blackness and not just
being painted with one brush stroke so I
feel the difference for sure yeah I
definitely think that there is
difference but I do think that the bar
for black people is exceptionally high
like Tim's movies have made over a
billion dollars girl trips made 150 like
these are stats that black people have
to have to work period
s like I'm like what and the fact that
like these opportunities are limited to
the artists that have to prove
themselves in that way already
eliminates so many other people from
doing it so I think that like that first
of all that's that's [ __ ] uh and then
like as like a queer black man that is
not a representation that I see so even
if the change is happening personally
not quick enough is not happening to me
personally like I feel like there needs
to be a greater
push and
the implications of knowing who is
telling these stories how they get to
tell these stories and the gates that
are stopping them from telling those
stories and then busting those shits
down because clearly mathematically it's
not working like yeah there's change but
it's too small make it quick the world's
ending Dwayne you're a queer black man
and you had to write a movie
yeah I will say that a lot of people and
I'm not I want to be careful as I say
this but a lot of people in Hollywood
end up writing their own project to get
into the door because that's the way
that so many people have have broken
through is to Dem because otherwise the
you know the door is not open yeah you
know it's um but look I will say that I
I have seen many movies like this but I
have never seen this movie if this makes
any sense with the blackening like uh
and I'm really really happy that it was
made and it's really good and I know I
know that it's going to play great
tonight like I'm I'm sure I see a lot of
movies I'm very confident
um and obviously I wish you guys nothing
but the best and if you can't tell we're
ending the interview because I need to
rush to a movie
I I really want to say congratulations
and um I I hope it's a huge hit for you
guys me too thank you